welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday my name is lack Lakshmanan
and i'm going to be talking about a
development workflow when you're
building end-to-end machine learning
models with tensorflow
google cloud platform you can ask
questions anytime and we have Googlers
on standby to answer them
so this talk that I'm going to be doing
is basically going to be walking through
a set of code labs and the code lab is
here on that link and it's essentially
about building an end-to-end machine
learning model we'll walk through all of
the steps in order to do that but before
we do that let's talk a little bit about
what machine learning looks like on
Google cloud so what we're going to be
doing is that we're going to be using
distributed tensorflow
on cloud ml engine and when you look at
tensorflow you have the varying levels
of abstraction levels with the bottom
level essentially being how you run core
tensorflow
in c++ but more commonly people do core
tensorflow
in python which essentially calls the
C++ API to get high performance on a
variety of different devices whether
they're CPUs GPUs etc the the level at
which we would be working at will be TF
that estimator this is this very high
level out-of-the-box API that handles
distributed training for you so why do
you why do we talk about distributed
transfer flow well mean you look at a
lot of machine learning frameworks they
can handle what I call toy problems toy
problems are problems where the input
fits into memory well you take your data
your inputs you train your model and you
have your model right and if all you
have are small data sets and that's fine
and that's what I call a toy problem but
in order to build effective machine
learning you need three things and the
first and foremost thing that you need
is large amounts of data and if you have
big data if you have large amounts of
data then batching and distribution
become extremely important you need to
take your inputs and you can't read all
of them from memory all of ones
you have to break it up into chunks and
read them you can't go ahead and train
your model all at work on one CPU or GPU
you often have to distribute to multiple
compute nodes and once you have batching
and you have distribution and this is
something that you need when you have
large data sizes then tend to flow
starts to play a huge role the other
thing that you need when you want to
build effective machine learning is that
you need what's called feature
engineering this is where you don't use
a raw inputs as this but you take your
raw inputs and you do transformations of
them you may pre-process those inputs
you may create features and we look at
examples of those and it's on those
features that you train your model and
the reason to do this is that the raw
data it can be pretty noisy cannot and
can be relatively hard and we take many
many many epochs and a much more complex
model for the model to learn from the
raw data where if you have if you've
done feature engineering it might be
easier for your model to learn so the
third thing that you need when you want
to build effective machine learning is
that you need to be able to experiment
with a variety of different model
architectures and that's another place
where tensorflow comes in extremely
handy because it is the most popular
tool for deep learning and importantly
it's very popular both among researchers
and among developers so what that means
is that when you're developing with
tensorflow
you get the benefit of essentially being
able to build models that are leading
edge and you get to do this often by
basically taking open source code and
applying it to your data so that's
essentially what tensorflow provides but
what else does a machine learning
framework need to provide besides the
ability to handle large data the ability
to do feature engineering and the
ability to the experimental model
architectures what else do we need well
one thing is hyper parameter tuning sure
you can train a model but
times you don't train a model you train
a family of models and you want to
basically go ahead and do this
experimentation easily in an automated
way and that's where hyper parameter
tuning comes in another thing that you
may want to do is that once you have
your model you have clients you're
accessing this model and you need to
basically Auto scale the prediction code
so that if you have a hundred clients or
a million clients your prediction API
scales and so you want your client code
to be able to access your model not
through Python not through tensorflow
but with just a REST API call so that
you basically are able to access this
prediction model from pretty much any
device any language that you want but
then the question becomes if the client
is basically going to be making REST API
calls who's going to do all of the
pre-processing and feature creation
because your model the model that you
deployed expects to see these new
features so who's going to do that
because what the client wants to give is
the raw data and that's where Cloud ml
engine comes in cloud ml engine helps
you to basically do auto tuning helps
you to scale out your predictions and
helps you maintain it in such a way that
you get repeatable results between
training and between prediction okay so
the way we go through the development
workflow on ml engine is that you start
with data lab and data lab is a Jupiter
notebook that's hosted so you basically
start with data lab which is Jupiter
notebook and you do it on a small data
set maybe you have a CSV file you're
doing your exploration and pandas you
may be using Apache beam and then you're
writing a tensor flow model you're
improving it and then you get a model
that works and once you have a model
that works you don't know how well it
works and the way you basically figure
out how well it works is that you take
it now and you scale it out to your
entire data set and you do that on
Google Cloud where you're basically
using things like cloud dataflow to do
your pre-processing use your reading
your data of cloud storage and you're
running your model on many machine
it's using ml engine and that helps you
and all of these things are serverless
you don't have to manage any clusters
you don't have to manage an
infrastructure so that's basically the
end-to-end workflow that I'm going to be
walking through so we're gonna start
with how to take your data explore it
visualize it and then to create a
smaller part of that data to play around
with to create your sample data set and
then to be able to develop your first
tensor flow model and having gotten your
model you want to now try it out on the
entire data set so you go back and you
create your training and evaluation data
sets that are large that are over the
entire data and having done that you
execute the training this model that you
have developed you execute that training
you deploy it and then you basically
access it from other clients for example
from a web application so these are the
like seven kind of steps in this and
this link takes you to the code lab and
to the github repository so here is a
code lab and here's a github repository
that contains all of these notebooks so
that's notebook one that's notebook two
notebook three etc all the way so we'll
basically go ahead and walk through each
of them one by one so the first thing is
to explore the data now the model that
I'm going to be doing is going to be a
structured data model and you might say
well a second you're doing structured
data isn't that boring well it's kind of
boring yes images and sequences get all
the press but even at Google where we've
been doing machine learning for a long
time
MLP multi-layer perceptrons which are
basically the kind of model that you use
for structured data that is nearly
two-thirds of all the models that we
have in production LST ms which are
sequence models the kinds of things that
you do for time series and for text
they're another 30% the the hello world
M lists of the world the images that's
less than 5% of production models so if
you're starting out in machine learning
and you're saying what should I
concentrate on where you start is with
structured data so that's where we're
going to start okay so our goal here is
that we want to predict the weight of a
newborn so this is a healthcare data
set and the idea is that if we can
predict the weight of a newborn we can
identify babies that may need special
facilities incubators etc and then get
babies that care that they need so the
idea is that a pregnant woman walks into
a doctor's office and based on a variety
of measurements that the doctor has they
want to be able to predict what the
weight of the newborn is which is a
pretty good indicator of the health of
the baby ok so how do we do that we need
a data set and the data set that we're
going to use is an open data set
collected by the US government it's all
the birds record in the 50 states in the
US so this is called the natality data
set
it's about 137 million rows pretty
reasonable size data that we can use to
demonstrate the kinds of things that we
want to do so this data set includes
things like you know the the birth right
the day after the date of birth the
location of the birth also the baby's
birth weight and pounds this is gonna be
our label this is the thing that we're
trying to predict and things like the
mother's age at the time of birth the
gestation weeks how long was a pregnancy
was that a preemie pregnancy was a
full-term etc so those are the kinds of
features that we have that we can use as
predictors to predict the weight of the
baby so first thing to explore and
visualize the data set so if you go to
the codelab link there so number one is
to explore the data so we're basically
going to go ahead and go into the cloud
shell icon so I already have that
running here so there it is here's my
cloud shell okay and in here I can go
into cloud shell I can then basically
run the first command G cloud compute
zones list okay which is here so go down
there g-cloud compute zones list this
tells me all the computers owns that are
available and you want to go ahead and
pick a zone that's close by to where you
live to reduce your latency and to
basically have your compute in in that
particular region the next step
is to basically go ahead and create a
data lab VM just to save time up I've
already done this so I'll skip that step
and the third thing is to go into the
bigquery console so we can go to the
bigquery console by going into the here
into the GCP console
going down let's go into the bigquery
there is bigquery and once we are in
bigquery we want to go ahead and compose
a query and the query that we want to
compose is this okay okay and we want to
do this in standard sequel so let's go
ahead and do standard seek well another
way to do this is to go into show
options and turn off the legacy sequel
query so let's go ahead and do the
standard sequel that is the query that I
want to run the query is that I'm going
into this data set called public samples
natality and I'm basically picking up
all the birds separate between 2000 and
2005 let me go ahead and run the query
and I'm basically going ahead and
finding the plurality the plurality is
whether a single child was born whether
it's twins
whether it's triplets whether it's
quadruplets or quintuplets so we see for
example that single kids are obviously
the highest there were about half a
million five hundred thousand or so
twins and about 28,000 triplets etc so
that's the data set and remember this is
a huge data set right hundred and thirty
seven million rows we were able to
process it in about four seconds okay so
that's that's a power of bigquery here
and we didn't create a cluster we didn't
set up any infrastructure I just went
into bigquery and I said this is a
cluster one this is the query that I
want to run and at that point thousands
of nodes essentially processed my query
for me and that's why I was able to get
back the results on this pretty large
data set I'm only picking two columns
are actually three columns which is why
only three gigs of data got processed so
bigquery is a columnar database it
only processes the columns that your
query actually references and we were
able to basically go ahead and get our
results back so let's go ahead into the
next step in here and so this is cool I
get my table the table isn't very
interesting what we want our graphs
we're data scientist we want graphs so
let's go into cloud data lab it's a
cloud this is cloud data lab okay and in
cloud data lab let's go ahead and start
in your notebook and in that notebook
that I have started let me go ahead and
take essentially a very similar query so
here's my notebook I will go ahead and
set up my query and I'm basically
importing the bigquery package and I'm
basically getting DF which is a panda's
data frame and I'm go ahead and doing DF
Godhead which shows me the first few
elements of that data frame just to make
sure that we have something reasonable
to plot so this is essentially doing the
same thing that we did on the bigquery
console but I'm now doing it from Python
from my data lab notebook and the next
cell we want to do this so let's do this
okay
so we see that we basically got a few
now a few of the rows the weight in
pounds where the baby was male or not
the mother's age etc but the next thing
that I want to do is to basically go
ahead and get the distinct values of a
particular column is it is the baby male
or is it baby female and go ahead and do
a bar plot so let's go ahead and do this
so this is kind of where Python starts
to come in really useful so we can
basically do all of our normal plotting
that we do in Python and we see for
example that there are a few more male
babies and there are female babies that
are born and this is the actually this
is the average weight so this is
essentially the male babies are slightly
heavier than female babies and we can
also do the same thing for gestation
weeks so I'll go ahead and do this for
gestation weeks and notice that each of
these things that I'm doing I'm doing
the
pretty interactively but each of this
piece of lines of color actually
processing hundreds of millions of line
off rows of data right so now we're
basically seeing that there are let me
just make the slightly bigger okay so
with 17 the week of pregnancy eighteenth
week of pregnancy etc you see that the
weight of the babies tends to go up and
then basically once the babies get
almost full-term it kind of evens out so
that's as that's the first step we've
explored the data we've kind of seen how
the average weight which is the kind of
thing that we want to predict how it
varies with one predictor in this case
the gender of the baby and another
predictor which is the gestation weeks
how long has the pregnancy lasted so
let's move back to this so that was the
first step to explore and visualize the
data set we did that with data lab using
bigquery okay and having done this we
basically got graphs like this that said
that sure the gender of the baby matters
sure the plurality I did not show you
this but you could also do other columns
in the data set so in this case we're
the single child or twins etc twins tend
to be a lower weight than single
children for example so you can
basically go ahead and do this and find
which features matter so having done
that we have now identified our
predictors and we are often to basically
do the next step which is to basically
no use to go ahead and create our data
set based on those predictors that we
have chosen so to build a machine
learning model the first step is to
create the data set that is to go ahead
and pull out the important predictors
we've now explored the data we're ready
to go ahead and create the data set and
to create the data set right we need to
also think about one more thing and the
thing that we need to think about is
causality will we actually know the sex
of the baby in the plurality of the baby
so that we can predict it
predict the weight of a baby well we
will if an ultrasound is carried out we
won't if there was no ultrasound so what
we need to do is we need to have figure
out a way to work with this partial data
sometimes we know the data sometimes you
know the prediction where the predictor
and sometimes we don't so let's look at
how to basically create the sample data
set in bigquery so here we'll move on to
step number two to create the data set
and there I will basically go ahead in
data lab I will clone the notebook
so let's go down here and in here let's
just clone the notebook and this will
essentially go to github pull in the
code and at this point I can go into
here and I see my training data analyst
and in there so this just prevents her
from having to copy and paste code every
time I can go into the directory that's
pointed out so so this is the same
github repo that was that I showed you
earlier so deep dive and this is the
structured data and in there we are now
on to the second of the labs and in this
lab right the but once a notebook comes
up you notice that there are three lines
here about the bucket and the project
those are in quick labs so we'll go into
quick labs and get the project ID and
basically throw that in here so that's
my project ID and the region is fine and
I need to go ahead and have a bucket so
let's just make sure that the bucket
exists so we can go down to the GCP
console go into storage and once we are
in storage we see that yes there is a
bucket and the bucket is actually the
same name as a project conveniently
enough so we can basically go down here
and it's essentially that
and we will basically create you sad
bucket and we can run that we can run
the next cell and having done that you
don't need to create it the buckets
already there and now we can sample the
data set so I'm just going ahead and
running them one by one you can click
run here what I'm doing is I'm pressing
shift enter but there now I'm grouping
by the hash Munt and getting my training
data and once I have my training data
and I'll stop running through it because
it's essentially the results are here we
can basically look at what the data set
looks like we can look at the weight in
pounds which on average is 7.2 pounds
but the standard deviation is about 1.3
pounds a minimum baby was half a pound
and the maximum baby was almost 14
pounds the mother's age again you have
it but notice something interesting the
weight in pounds in the mother's age
there are different numbers what would
that be well because sometimes you have
missing data and pandas doesn't count
nulls and so we have some babies in our
data set for whom the weight wasn't
recorded we have some pregnancies a lot
of pregnancies looks like for which that
gestation weeks aren't known so we need
to deal with that as well so what we are
doing is that in our pre-processing in
pandas we make sure that the weight in
pounds is greater than 0 that the
mother's age is greater than 0 that the
gestation weeks is greater than 0 and
the plurality is greater than 0 so we're
just filtering the data to make sure
that we're only dealing with valid data
sets and then remember what we talked
about that sometimes you know it and
sometimes you don't so here's how we're
dealing with it we're basically taking
the numbers 1 2 3 & 4 & 5 and replacing
them with single twins triplets etc and
we are basically going to simulate the
lack of an ultrasound so for every row
in our input data will create one more
row and the second row is going to be a
copy of the first row except the
plurality is only going to be single or
multiple the idea being that we don't
know if it's twins or triplets
we do know if it's one kid or two kids
and the gender of the baby is going to
be unknown so now the gender of the baby
can be three possible values male/female
or unknown and the plurality can be
single twins triplets quadruplets
quintuplets but also multiple plus so
that's the basic thing that will appear
in our data and we create that pandas
dataframe and we basically go ahead and
write it all out okay so at this point
if you go ahead and look at here the
slope we haven't run this yet so I can
go ahead and run all the cell's and at
this point all of the cells will get run
at the very end I will basically have my
CSV files that I can now use for the
next step which is to basically train my
transfer flow model so let's move back
here and now I'm going to basically move
fast because I think you get the idea of
how you walk through this okay
so one of the things that I kind of
glossed over as I went through was that
the way I split my data was that I
didn't use R and instead what I did was
that I used a hash and the reason to use
a hash rather than a Rand is that in in
this dataset and this is going to be
common with a lot of different datasets
is that the rows are not actually
independent of each other if you have
triplets you have three babies so you
have three rows in your data and those
three rows are for the same mom so it's
the same number of gestation weeks the
same mother's age the same everything so
they're not really independent rows and
you don't want to actually put those
rows in like one of those rows and
training and of another of the rows in
evaluation so what we do is that we make
a hash of the row and we divide based on
the hash so we've now created our sample
data set the next step is to build the
model to build the model the thing to
realize is that there are two types of
features in our data we have dense
features and we have sparse features
dense features are features like the
price which is a continuous number as
sparse feature is a categorical feature
like an employee ID or know the gender
of the baby is it male is it female or
is it unknown that
and that's a categorical variable so you
have dense variables and have sparse
variables and deep neural networks are
really good for dense highly correlated
data because of the way they work with
adding and subtracting data between
layers but on the other hand sports
networks are really well-suited to
linear models so if you have sparse
features you want to use linear models
you have dense features you want to use
deep neural networks but in this case we
have both so what did we do we use
what's called a wide and deep model
where we take all of our sparse features
and we put them into the wide part of
the network and we take all of our dense
features and we put them with the deep
part of the network and the way you do
this in tensorflow
is to use what is called a DNN linear
combined classifier so we're basically
going to do this and we're going to take
some of our features and say these are
our linear features and these are a DNN
features so let's go ahead and take a
quick look and in this case what I'll do
is I'll just step through the code on
github itself but you can basically do
this you can run the code and you can
train the model so here as bass before
you change your bucket your project and
having done that
here's a tensorflow code the import
tensorflow we say my dataset contains
these CSV columns the weight in pounds
is the is the baby male the mother's age
the plurality and the gestation weeks
and how and what we want to predict is
await in pounds and having done that to
read the data set I'm going to basically
go ahead and glob all filenames globbing
is basically putting in a while store
while lickin Asterix right so basically
go ahead and reading every all the files
that have a particular prefix because in
reality we will not reading one file
will be reading AB set of short files so
I'll be able to say train star so having
done that I say the set text data set we
did line by line and decode the CSV how
do I decode the CSV I take the CSV and
these are my columns right so basically
those are my defaults that's my columns
so for each of them take out the label
because that's not a feature so you have
your features which are one set of
columns and you have the label column
one column in the original data set so
having done that then go ahead and
shuffle the data shuffling is a good
thing to do in distributed training so
that each worker gets a different copy
of the data in essence or it's
processing a different slice of the data
at the same time and you basically go
ahead and repeat the data as many times
as you need and that's how you read the
data and now we basically say given our
data how do we form our white columns or
a deep columns well we basically say
that there is mail is a categorical
column mother's age is a numeric column
plurality is a categorical column and
this is the vocabulary and the gestation
weeks is a numeric column so you
basically specify what type of column it
is and that's our input data and what I
am now doing is that I'm gonna take my
common columns when you marry columns
and do what is called bucket izing I'm
going to discretize them to basically
put them into bins and in this case I'm
just putting them into bins of 15 to 45
in steps of 1 and then I'm gonna do the
same thing for the gestation weeks and
now my white columns are there is male
and the plurality those are both sparse
but also the discretized numeric columns
and having done that now this is kind of
where tensorflow comes in really handy
and then you can do all these very
sophisticated things so sure I've
discretized it but now I'm going to
basically go ahead and do my feature
crossing and I'm gonna feature cross
these extremely sparse data to basically
create in effect something like 20,000
new columns or feature crosses I can
afford to do this because my dataset is
very large so having done that I then do
dimensionality reduction to a set of 3
now the question is do you need to do
all this if I didn't do any of these
things if I just took my raw data and I
did it I would lose about 30% enormously
so I get about 30% improvement by doing
some of these sophisticated feature
crosses etc and then I basically create
my deep column so I have my wide and
deep and then I can train and evaluate
by creating a DNN linear regret the
white columns with the deep columns
and then saying what it is I need to do
for training I'm gonna retrained at CSV
what do I need to do hi evaluation
evaluate on eval dot CSV so that's
pretty much it and I do one thing else
and this is something that a lot of
people don't do but a very good thing to
do something that you want to get to the
habit of doing because it's going to be
useful for every step after this is that
I also export the model the reason to
export the model is to basically take my
model that have trained and put it into
a form where it can be quickly wrapped
up and used for production right so I
basically export my model and when
you're exporting a model you need to
think about remember I talked about the
rest API by which you access it so
here's the things that someone is going
to give us in that REST API they're
gonna give us the Ismail mother's age
plurality and gestation weeks what does
this look like right it basically looks
something like this somebody would be
able to go into and create an
application that looks like this where
that's the mother's age this is the
number of gestation weeks and I expect
that it is twins both of them are male
and go ahead and predict right so that's
essentially the idea that we want to do
when we are basically creating our
tensor flow model okay so having done
that the next step Kim is to pre-process
the data with data flow so we've created
a tensor flow model it's being developed
the next step is to operationalize the
model is to take that model and
operationalize it now this model that
we've created is ready to go except we
don't have the full data yet now the way
we created the small data set before was
to use pandas and this is fine for
experimenting but if you want to
operationalize your workflow you want to
make it repeatable you want to have a
deal with streaming data you want to do
your pre-processing not and pandas but
it's something that's very scalable
something like a patch a beam so that is
going to be our next lab and here and so
the idea is to basically write this
Apache beam pipeline and lob it off to
cloud dataflow which is a service that
will run this for us it
autoscale all of these predictions and
it'll basically give us a number of
things that are running okay so we are
now here on to the next notebook okay
which is on pre-processing and I'll skip
to the key part of this notebook and the
key part of this notebook is that we are
reading from bigquery we are reading the
data from bigquery and we are doing the
same things that we did in pandas except
that we are now doing it in Apache beam
so that it can also work on streaming
data so imagine that you have data about
birds coming in from all the clinics in
the country as they are streaming into
pub/sub you can read them you can do
this pre-processing and then you can
stream them out your database right so
we are basically creating a know
ultrasound and a width ultrasound and if
it's no ultrasound the gender is unknown
and then we're basically going ahead and
if the plurality is greater than one it
is multiple and I'm also right in when I
go ahead and do the query I do the
filtering as a year is a weight in
pounds greater than zero etc okay so we
basically go ahead and do this and we
lob it off now once you run this
notebook it will lob off the code into
data flow a few minutes later you will
basically have your large data set
that's been created on in this case of
five nodes in this case actually 15
nodes right the current CPU is 15 so it
just basically goes ahead and does it on
how many of our workers you specify okay
and having done that the next step is to
train on ml engine again next notebook
okay and the key point here in terms of
training is very very very
straightforward you have your code you
basically tell ml engine
here's my code it exists in this Python
package please train it for me
that's pretty much it right you run a
single command
it basically lobs it off and it creates
the machines if it's run a GPU it create
basically attaches GPUs to those
machines it does the training and the
trained model shows up on cloud storage
and once a trained model is on cloud
storage you're going to while its
training can do your
our monitoring etc then you deploy it
deploying again last notebook to deploy
it you basically it's again just a
single command line called again once
you write your tensor flow module
everything after that is essentially
just no single command line calls you
basically say g-cloud ml engine please
create a version of this model from this
tensor flow and then once that's
deployed any time it receives a JSON of
this form it basically go ahead and
sends back a prediction which is why
write something like this just works
right so we can say the mother's age is
30 there's 6.2 pounds if it's a single
child what is the prediction that 7.9
pounds etc right
boom boom boom you're basically getting
predictions back because you've
essentially deployed it okay then that's
pretty much the end-to-end process of
going ahead and building a model so
bottom line explore your data create
your sample data set create your
transfer flow model and then are
personalize it using data flow and using
ml engine okay and I'll skip this part
that's of just building a web
application and with that we will
basically just stay tuned for a live Q&A
and we'll be back in less than a minute
you
you
let's do that
okay Foursquare on the questions all
right okay so questions here first
question is there a way to do this
without using data lab can I use my own
Jupiter build absolutely right so data
lab is actually an open source thing so
let's go ahead and do github and search
for PI data lab which is the project
that's in and PI data lab is a package
so you can basically go ahead and do a
pip install of Pi data lab within within
Jupiter and then you will have all of
these capabilities that I talked about
all of the connections to bigquery and
ml engine etc so that's all you really
need so go into the Google Data lab
project data lab is the full notebook
itself but PI data lab is the library
that this thing uses and this is the
pipe installable package so you can go
ahead and install it from within
Jupiter's if you if you're using your
own Jupiter build no problem at all you
can still do it do all this next
question why did he use cloud dataflow
to do the pre-processing what are my
other options I think like in particular
can I use something like spark
absolutely right the reason I used cloud
dataflow is because I always think about
streaming and streaming to me as the is
the limit of where things are going to
go anything that you're doing in batch
today people want to do things faster
and faster and the limit of that is that
you want to do that as the data comes in
and the nice thing about doing doing it
in data flow is that it's the same code
that works on both batch data historical
data and newly arriving data or
streaming data but you could do this in
spark the only problem is that you will
have to write it twice once for batch
once in spark streaming third question
how much does all this cost to do on
Google Cloud not very much actually the
dataflow job to go ahead and dataset was
apart maybe two or three dollars the ml
engine to go ahead and do the entire
training cost me maybe about eight or
nine dollars
think you could do this entire workflow
end-to-end in under $20 and of course we
have a free trial offer so go to Google
cloud platform sign up for the tree
trial you get $300 so no perfectly
possible for you to go ahead and do all
of these code labs without spending any